rich I want to Pivot back to the book
here there's a big chapter in your book
the 20 red flags I think the top 20 is
it the is it the 20 or is it the top 20
and if it's the top 20 what is one two
that maybe you've left off the list yeah
that there's there's actually 21 in the
second edition I added another one which
is a woman that's not willing to enter
your frame and follow your lead uh but
there's loads and loads of red flags out
there like these are the main ones I
mean I could write an entire book and
just call it the red flag book and put
hundreds of hundreds of red flags the
problem is is that that's really going
discourage men from dealing with women
entirely I mean already giving them a
list of 20 as like well my ex-wife had
all 18 of them or my last ex-girlfriend
had you know 19 it's like well you know
like these things exist and you're
starting to connect the dots because
they're problematic now you can invite a
woman into your life on a long-term
basis make her your girlfriend make her
your wife whatever it is that you decide
to do with red flags it's not that you
can't do it it's just understand that if
you do it you're going to invite
unnecessary chaos problems drama stress
potential Financial consequences maybe
losing access to your kids because she's
a potential you know red flag down the
road um so vetting women I think is
something that guys need to get good at
and I figured the easiest way to do that
is just make call them red flags and
then summarize what the main red flags
happen to be that I saw pop up the most
in my life and the coaching calls that I
had with my clients and I've had
thousands of people that call in my co
podcast because I do Q&A segments for
free on there sort of thing so I just
took what looked like to me as the most
common red flags that exist in women put
them in a chapter and said hey guys you
know date these women if you want but
just know that you're inviting a
nightmare in your life and if you want
to have a more pleasant life a woman
that's going to complement your life and
not be the focus of it try to avoid most
of these women if you can right or if
she's got one or two of the red flags
just make sure she's working on them you
know for example like um like one that a
woman could work on is a addiction you
know she's a drinker you know for
example well if she's drinking Booze too
much or she's smashes back boxes of wine
you know with her girlfriends that's
going to be a problem for you at some
point down the road and if she
recognizes that's a problem and she's
doing something about it that's that's a
woman that you might want to contemplate
keeping around in your life yeah I think
some of them kind of kind of feed into
each other I'm just kind of looking at
the list here you know I would say you
know a feminist is going to be more
likely to probably be a party girl she's
gonna be more likely to probably have
tattoos and piercings she's going to be
more likely to throw hisy fits you know
a woman with daddy issues is probably
gonna be more likely to maybe have a
higher Notch count because she seek
validation in other men so I think some
of them kind of feed in so would you say
there's a hierarchy and what's maybe the
top five that like if we can kind of
give the guys here today like begin to
look for these and if you can yeah let's
do a top five that are an absolute no-o
Zone like a red light for sure um I'm G
to say feminists for sure um the problem
with feminists is they've got a victim
mindset and if you're going to play the
victim card then you have to have an
oppressor and the oppressor for
feminists is always men it's always a
patriarchy right so at some point um you
know push is going to come to shove and
she's going to side with The Sisterhood
and you're just going to be called a
entitled male or entitled white male or
some nonsense like that so um they're
just miserable to be around so that's so
that would be number one um the next one
I would say on the list would be violent
women um there there should be no place
in your life for women that snap they
can't control their emotions they throw
things at you um these are the kinds of
women that will that will get you hauled
way in handcuffs and in the backseat of
a cruiser even though she initiated the
whole thing um they're not they're not
worth dating they're not worth friends
with benefits they're like just stay
away from them if you if you hear any
stories about her uh being violent in
her past um a good question to ask her
is hey have you ever been in the
backseat of a police car you know just
casual conversation you have a date
chitchat blah blah blah hey you ever
been in the backseat of a police car you
know sort of thing and it's funny
because if they have been they love
singing like a canary and they'll tell
you the story right um so that would be
the next one f um tattoos and piercings
I'm going to say um is something that
some guys might have a preference for
but with everybody that I've talked to
and I've talked to a lot of doctors now
I've talked to psychologists I've talked
to uh sons of doctors that are they
product of a lineage of doctors and
surgeons and it's like these guys all
make the same observation every woman
that sort of comes in another clinic
with issues uh is in a ER room or any of
these things uh they
they've created the drama of their
circumstances that they're in and
there's a direct correlation between the
tattoos and the markings on their body
and the that's going on in
their life so to me it's a red flag
again I understand some guys have a
preference for it uh try dating women
without tattoos is you know one thing
that I could at least recommend you
trying what is that that's three um so
the next one I'm going to give to Big
Notch counts you absolutely positively
cannot be in a long-term relationship
with a woman that shared her body with
dozens and dozens of guys it's
disgusting when you think about it um
the data is also very very clear that if
you marry a woman and have children with
her the chances of you having a
successful marriage over a long-term
basis where she's committed to you and
the family and the children and all
these things dramatically drops with
every man that she shared her body with
in fact the number starts to go downhill
after three and three is a pretty
nominal number for most women today
because if you're in your 30s for
example and dating women around your age
you're a little bit younger it's not
that uncommon for them to have slept
with a few dozen guys right um so
there's that and I mean if I had to pick
one more I'm going to go with single
moms you know single like there's a
chapter in my book where I where I talk
about specifically why it's not a good
idea to date a woman with kids and this
is coming from a man with a child right
like I have a daughter uh there's only
one circumstance which I talk about in
the book where it might be ideal but for
the vast majority of men it boils down
down to you're going to have
responsibility to another man's children
without any Authority whatsoever so when
things don't go well when you try to
enforce boundaries when you try to lay
down the rule of the law because trust
me you're going to be expected to pay
for dinners and attend birthday parties
and take them on vacations and all this
kind of stuff and help Little Billy zoom
in the scope on his BB gun and all that
sort of stuff but if they misbehave and
you try to set boundaries the vast
majority of women uh that bring children
in tow sometimes uh multiple children
from multiple men uh you're going to
have the baby daddy drama and you're
going to have responsibility of those
kids which you're cucked in essentially
meaning um you're essentially abandoning
your sexual strategy to go raise another
man's kids with no authority to raise
those kids you you'll be treated like an
ATM your financial resources will be
welcomed but the boundaries that you set
usually aren't so it's like the juice is
not worth the squeeze in those type of
scenarios what would be the one case
where maybe it would be okay yeah that's
a good question so um if you've got a
small child so when I got divorced uh my
daughter was 4ish or you know something
like that and one of the one of the
problem areas for um women as they
become adults is uh people aren't
staying together generally speaking like
the best household for children to be
raised in is a two parent household
after that it's the father raising the
kids after that it's the mom so men do a
far better job raising kids as a single
parent versus women dad is very very
clear on that so the problem that you
can run into is if you're a dad with a
daughter and you meet a woman and she's
got two or three sons for example
blood rated siblings are not attracted
to each other they don't touch each
other they're not sexually attracted to
each other they're not interested
whatsoever because of um evos pych you
know discovering this that um we want
genetic diversity like uh it's one of
the reasons why I think teenagers become
so disagreeable like you know when their
kids are very agreeable and they turn
into teenagers then that would be around
the same time that a young child 2,000
years ago or a teen you for example
might have left the tribe and gone to
another tribe genetic diversity they
want to leave they want want to do
things on the road they want to explore
sort of thing and I think that's true
today as well only you know you just
deal with a disagreeable teenager that
doesn't want to listen to anything that
you say but the problem in a household
is if you're living in a house with your
daughter and she brings her sons into
your house and let's say you blend
families because that's always their
idea oh let's blend families you know
we'll just be like The Brady Bunch and
live together sort of thing everything
will be Ticky boo I can't tell you how
many women that I met when I was dating
post divorce that were violated as
children by either a stepfather or a
stepsibling in that same household so
that's a that's a huge problem so the
only scenario where I would say for a
guy like me where it might be acceptable
is she's got a kid same sex as my
daughter obviously same age roughly so
they can be friends they can do cool
together and entertain each other
sort of stuff like that and she doesn't
have any of the red flags and she's not
obese and you know she's attractive and
she's got genuine burning desire like
and and and all these things which is I
mean like we're talking about finding a
pot of gold at the end of a rainbow you
know type of scenario so you know the
probability of that happening uh may
exist but it's pretty low like I think
when I was dating there was one G that
had a kid that had a daughter the same
age as mine and she was super attractive
and but like nothing ever took off right
so I think for the vast majority of guys
you're just better off dating women
without kids even if you're a father
with a kid I still think you're better
off dating a woman that doesn't have
kids I really hope you guys enjoyed that
clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out